[Music]
we're at the Apple event 2019 I'm so
excited because today they announced the
iPhone 11 now they also announced these
two new guys these are the iPhone 11
pros this is the max version and this is
the not max version this is the new Mac
space gray color they also have a silver
and the gold and a new midnight green
which we're gonna check out here in a
second they had a bunch of really cool
announcement so this is just a first
look at the new iPhone 11s there's a lot
to check out so I guess let's just get
started
[Music]
they have three new cameras so we have
the main camera the ultra wide and the
telephoto so you do a lot of really cool
camera tricks to this there's also a new
front-facing camera update you can now
shoot in slow-mo and you're gonna shoot
4k and 4k 60 which is pretty incredible
let's chest out a slo-mo front-facing
video they're calling the slow-mo front
facing videos slow fees so let's shoot
my first slow feet are you ready yeah
yes
that's pretty great things new in me
camera this is pretty awesome so you'll
have the different lenses that you can
switch to so it goes new three lenses
he'll be able to choose right here just
by tapping but if you press and hold
this will give you the little dial here
so you'll be able to choose which zoom
you'd like all the way up to 6x digital
but if you're taking pictures and you're
like oh I want to take a video you press
and hold and then slide and that
automatically will start recording you
can also live switch to lenses they also
showed a really cool demo of filmic Pro
some of you guys that may use filmic Pro
before but they're implementing
something really incredible you'll be
able to use their app and film and
record multiple camera angles at the
same time which is kind of crazy because
if you want to do a multi camera shoot
you'll just need one phone so now I'm
inside of the app and these are all of
my camera options that I can choose from
Ultra might tell a little wide and the
selfie so let's use the selfie and the
ultra wide I'm gonna click confirm and
now
I'm reporting at the same time this is
incredible this is good I'm like turned
logging into like an art form I mean it
already is a whole nother level this is
so great I can fill myself and film
what's happening around me another cool
thing is that you're taking a selfie and
you flip it it'll automatically zoom out
just like that so you can press it or
it'll just automatically do it when you
rotate to fit everyone into the photo
it's also a new portrait mode option
just like previous you've got all these
color options they have a new one it's
the high key light mono what are the
other big highlights is being able to
edit video on the go so let's do a
little video here front-facing hello
basically you can treat video like
photos now so you can add filters and do
color correction which is something that
has been definitely needed at the iPhone
11 Pro max thing is incredible let's go
check out a few of the other colors and
of course let's check out those iPhone
11 because that new lavender purple
color beautiful I'm still hoping for
this color one day
so here's the gold one I kind of wanted
the silver but now that I see the gold I
mean I'm such a sucker for rose gold
that I don't know what I'm gonna do
here's the midnight green this is both
of the versions I'm really surprised at
this this color I actually really really
like it it was kind of hard to see what
the color actually looked like but now
looking at it in person it's almost kind
of a little like a bluish green so I
guess the midnight green is a pretty
accurate naming convention look at it
and now here's the silver version of the
iPhone 11 Pro and the x11 Pro max these
look awesome I'm honestly still up in
the air I don't know which color to get
so behind me are all of the new iPhone
11 phones these are the brand-new colors
one of the things that we thought is
they were going to be calling them the
iPhone webinar but they're not it is
just the iPhone 11
[Music]
they also came out with the new Apple
watches this is a Series five and I'm so
excited because I'm such a huge fan of
the Apple watch that the Apple watch
actually did change my life like it got
me off the couch it got me hiking and
being way more motivated to close those
rings another thing that's really cool
is they're getting more into health
research so there's going to be a
research app that you can opt into so
the people can study the various data
that you choose to share and obviously I
know privacy is a huge concern so one of
the things that they didn't mention is
it won't be associated with you it'll
all be anonymous I mean I should
probably get the titanium and buy it
with my titanium app and card and then
I'll get 3% back so it's basically like
I'm saving money right the main
highlight though of the Series five it
has an always-on wash display so you'll
be able to have access to your watch at
any time and you won't have to do that
infamous arm flip another new feature is
the compass my sister and I hiked a lot
and we're always wondering what is our
elevation and are we actually going in
the right direction and I cannot wait to
take this out and hike with it
so this is the dark titanium and this
looks amazing
we also have one of the new Hermes
commands with the stainless steel I'm
such a fan of this always-on display as
you can tell it just slightly gets
darker
but it doesn't change you still see all
of the complications which you normally
would see what it's on and here's the
gold one this is one of my favorites as
well I definitely will miss the gold
because I really liked it but I think
that ceramic is calling my name
here it is we just got a ceramic
incoming this looks so great I feel good
this is gonna look with the silver
iPhone so you can see if they now made
this inner circle black with a red ring
this is so beautiful oh my gosh so right
now I'm testing out Apple Arcade this is
the first time that I'm seeing it and
this is so fun and one of the cool
things is you're able to connect
controllers it actually feels like I'm
playing on a console but I'm playing on
an iPad so this is the new iPad is the
seventh generation is the new ten point
seven inch screen what's cool this is
you
use a new iPad OS so you'll be able to
use a pencil you can use the smart
connect keyboard and you can also which
I'm a huge fan of is you can plug in a
SD card reader so you can import files
and photos and obviously you can connect
a controller and I'm gonna play Frogger
right now this is in the new apple
arcade so it's gonna be $4.99 a month
you could have access to all of these
games they'll be updating them monthly
and there's just something about using a
controller and playing on an iPad
I don't even unspeak well guys that was
the first look here from the Apple event
I had so much fun checking out all the
new phones and the Apple watches oh my
gosh I cannot wait it is officially
iPhone season it is here make sure you
guys like this video and make sure you
subscribe so it will be alerted when I
post new videos because there will be
plenty more Apple content coming up soon
I'll see you soon bye